i'm going to be so crap at this game
because i don't watch tv all you need to
know is that whether it's one of from
our show or not still don't have a clue
[Music]
i'm going to go first
i'm going to grind his [ __ ] bones to
make my bread that actually isn't from
our show
i'm gonna say that's from succession
actually is it the right answer yes i
thought so because you know what i hear
brian cox i'm gonna grind these [ __ ]
bones to make my bread okay bye
if you can quote the rules
you can [ __ ] obey them
i don't think it's from our show do you
want to hazard a guess as to what it
might be from if it isn't from our show
no i've got absolutely naught idea well
you're right it's not from our show it's
actually tony soprano from the sopranos
if you can quote the rules you can
[ __ ] obey them if you can quote the
rules you can [ __ ] obey him you hear
me
okay my turn i'm hoping i can't undo it
i'm not going to try and undo it
you go to war with the army you have
right that's not from our show either
but i don't know what it is from go to
war with the army you have right you go
to war with the army i'm not doing the
person no no and that's i thought i was
saying it wasn't for martial but now i'm
just thinking of a scene you go to war
with the army you have right okay i'm
gonna say it's for my show wrong answer
is sydney purcell beep oh my god i was
looking at you the other day boy i just
wish i ordered a plate of useless
[ __ ]
but you go to war with the army you have
right here we go it's meant to be shared
grief it's insurmountable too difficult
to battle to be waged alone i'm going to
hazard a guess that it may be from our
show i think it might be one of the
things that one of the girls say to each
other like alison and raniera might say
to each other okay
so
and that's the wrong only wrong answer
it's yeah it's actually from wrong show
big little lies
it's meant to be shared you know grief
it's
insurmountable too difficult to battle
to be raged alone
last one
[Laughter]
that could mean so many different things
one must not await the storm
[Laughter]
i'm going to get on a limb here
and say that that is from our show i'm
also going to get on the limb and say
that line is said by one lord cordless
valyrian the sea snake to elude a storm
you can either sail into it
or around it
but you must never await its coming
you